So let's talk about Agile and in particular distributed Agile.
So you should generally be familiar with Agile
as it came up in the 169 course ... you may have seen
some of the Dilbert cartoons on the topic
which are I think um … sometimes are … somewhat close to the mark in that of course
Agile as a concept has become very broad lots of people are using its
... you know I think there's there's an idea that
it's just sort of just like start hacking, start coding and
you know just do more work with fewer people and so on
... you know I think if
used inappropriately that's what it can feel like.
Ken Schwaber who's the scrum co-inventor ... says that you know - "Agile
can lower the risks associated with doing development" but it won't -
it won't show you how to actually do the coding ...
so it kinda, it's challenging.
Let's sort of consider the main alternative,
again already introduced to you in the 169 course, this big design upfront
typified by the waterfall.  There's other, spiral other things
... but just - you know - for review; the waterfall process has
this idea that
you know you can get all the requirements like done and set in stone
and when you finish doing the requirements and you move on
to design, and implementation and so on and the idea really is that
if you've got the specification precisely what you want in
enough detail then you can exactly produce
the software that the customer wants, it'll cost the appropriate
amount and be delivered on time and so on and so forth ...
and you know, I think in principal
the waterfall approach can work or other variations on it -
but it assumes that you've got a really wonderful understanding,
an absolutely fantastic understanding of requirements at the start
and you know ... there's lots of pieces to it. There's
different phases we can see in the diagram in the previous slide; checkpoints,
deliverables;
we're trying to finish you know each phase before we move on to the next one
... and I think that there there is the sort of sensible thing under there is that
yes if you can work out that you know
a … a bug earlier in the process then you can save yourself a lot of time
later on; if we look back at the flow, if you can work out
the right way to design something before you're actually constructing
it and you've put the are hundreds and hundreds of hours into creating something,
if you can work out that error earlier on then yes
absolutely fantastic and this sort of comes from the
civil engineering; mechanical engineering world ...
where making changes you know later on is prohibitively expensive
but software as we know is - is somewhat different
and so sort of in a reaction to waterfall
and ther related things critics have you know said
it's difficult to really know what the requirements are in advance it's - it's
also
a lot of the time you're working with technology, new software is coming
along all the time
you're not sure what it's able to do ... lots of testing required.
So one of the things that came up was this manifesto for Agile Software development.
It's I think about, coming up to about thirteen years ago
now and I imagine many of you have heard this before but just to
to review that they sort of set up
two styles here.  So sort of
valuing individual and interactions more than processes and tools;
we're valuing working software more than comprehensive documentation
you know we're more focused on customer collaboration than contract negotiation;
and more focused on responding to change over following a plan and
I think often you know in sort of the worst view of Agile you say right
no plans, no contracts, no documentation, no process and no tools, nothing, woo ooo ooo, let's all go run
around in a field and
roll around like rub ourselves with the code or something ...
the key think that's often missed is that we're talking about you know
what we don't want is you know the specifics of the contract
to have bound us so tightly that we can't actually work with the customer to work out
what they really want
... we don't want such a fantastic - enormous amounts of
energy focused on the plan and then following the plan that we can't
then respond to a change in the business needs, in this that and the
other
... you know that doesn't mean we don't want any documentation at all
but documentation can quickly go out of date so you know working software
working prototypes that people can say: "yes, that actually does do what I want"
is more valuable and you know getting people communicating with each
other
is you know more important than them necessarily using a particular process
or tool but again it's all about being flexible
... I'm so many of you've seen the old ... the tree swing
diagram which predates Agile by quite a long way
but I think it's, there's you know a mentality there about this
the danger that in a very
large-scale project that what people propose
gets handed off to another team and then a different team like
conceivably in waterfall you have entirely different groups of people
doing these different - different stages and and you get this
this danger of
things being fundamentally misinterpreted ... so it's ...
yeah ... it's not a panacea ... I'm certainly enjoying
you know using Agile and I think many other people are as well ... maybe we should just review
the Agile Principles. I mean it's ... I think, the proponents of Waterfall, proponents of Agile
can all agree right that we want to make
useful software and we want to make it ...
we want to keep customers satisfied and we want to do it within budget and
and all of these things and maybe where there's a difference of opinion sometimes is about how to
achieve that; the devil is in the details
but I think at least for me personally reading the Agile principles
it all makes a lot of sense and we'll see how this relates to
distributed teams in
a minute. But so ... yeah customer satisfaction by rapid delivery of
useful software so that's - that's critical yep, no complaint there
... welcoming requirement changes at all times and that sounds like that's
potentially challenging.
I think it's an acknowledgement really of the fact that business is changing fast.
If a company is working in a particular marketplace and you
know
a new challenge evolves it's like, well, actually we need a different thing
and you can sort of sit there and say: "well what you asked for was this so that's all we're gonna give
you"
... or you could say: "well you know ... okay ... how can we change what we've done
so far to meet
to meet that need" ... delivering
working software often, of the order of weeks rather than months or years; I mean
that's the
sort of critical thing really for human-computer interface from software
development
is just getting this you know as much as possible ...
feedback on have we built something that you want?
That can be very challenging of course if you can't engage with the
customer.  The customer says: "right, I want you to build
exactly this thing and don't talk to me for six months and come back and make it work".
Challenging ... obviously you've got to meet the customer halfway
in terms of how much time they can spend with you but yeah ...
the measure of progress is actually getting the working software out because
there's so many unknowns with the software
... ideally you want sustainable development maintaining a constant pace
... yeah, daily cooperation between everybody
... the people on the business side, the developers that's ...
I think thats ... it seems it, I mean some people say: "ooh you know
really really big projects that you need ... you know you must have Waterfall, you must have
spiral, or you must have like
reams and reams of documentation.  I guess this is - you get to very very large and things like the Affordable Health Care act and
there's all these
regulations and teams of lawyers and so on and it's a totally different scale
... even then, even if like it's just like one
little little pocket in a larger picture having this
communication you know regular communication and regular working with
prototypes
all the time just seems like ... how can you argue against that almost?  I guess
I'm biased but ... so interesting here also in the Agile Principles
is we've got ... face-to-face conversation best and so they recommend
colocation
in Agile and thats potential challenging. Right well distributed teams
is kind of out of the window, we'll come back to that in a minute.
... also you know you want motivated
individuals that you trust ... basically
if you've got a shall we say sort of an atmosphere or a culture of mistrust like we can't trust these people
to do
the right thing then it's maybe off to
kind of a non-starter. Other things in the Agile (Manifesto) continuous attention to technical
excellence and good design all the way through. Can anyone argue against that?
... simplicity. This simplicity; my simplicity scalpel
is often out in scrum meetings
doing the Agile process it's ... just
... complexity will kill almost any project that you start; whether
it's software or not, but particularly software products and so keeping things
absolutely absolutely simple as possible ... can't emphasize that enough
... trying to allow teams to find their own
organization-al structure that they prefer ...
you know rather than imposing a top down thing. The difficult thing is when you've got
you know reams and reams of procedures that you try and enforce top-down;
people just sort of resist them ... and this again ... coming back to changing
you know embracing change and then making changes to
handle that change. So anyway, you guys are probably already
reasonably familiar with Agile.  Agile;
so this is the broader idea; the Agile philosophy; and then we've got particular sort of Scrum is
the project management
framework.  That's what we'll talk ... talk more about that in
the next section and then we've got some XP
... which ... I don't hear that term used so much anymore but so
last week we were talking about distributed software development and a lot of those things
coming-out of the XP world but so let's
let's talk about distributed Agile and
this is ... I guess it's you know
these days everybody's working in a distributed framework
and it's becoming more and more common and I think people are starting to say: "Oh, right, actually
if we do have ... although
we would perhaps like to have face to face conversations
all the time new technologies like Skype and Google hangouts and other
sort of things are
making it so that you can do ... you can follow these Agile principles and you
can
conceivably even do it in a distributed environment.
The real challenges is the distributed meeting ...
is keeping people engaged ... the
technical issues are ... they still plague a distributed meeting
... working out how to handle those
even how to sometimes use those to your advantage
is key ... we'll talk more about this
next week but I mean in some ways
I would say yes these are troubles
I think engagement in ... I guess the key thing engagement is in a
a real life meeting you can kind of see that someone's attention has wandered and you
can maybe respond to that more easily
to a certain extent
... I think you can almost just except
if you doing Google hangouts and maybe you don't have as much
information about where people are looking but
you can see each of their screens that much more easily
in a - in a face to face meeting and you're all sitting round a table and you've all got
laptops or you're using a projector
it's actually I would argue harder to kinda see
what other people are looking at all the time.
I'd say that even the face-to-face office the standard boardroom is not -
is not necessarily, or a meeting room, is not necessarily perfectly designed in a way
that allows you to share details about interfaces and software
and so on. People often complain about a lack of them
stickies, the inability to do breakout meetings. These
actually to a degree ...
not - the notion ... there are various softwares for shared whiteboard and
stickies which then, they can have their own technical issues.
I personally find in the distributed Agile meetings that we do
for AgileVentures is that ... you can very easily have break outs because
anybody can start a new Hangout; you can easily grab people and say oh just let's
go and do a Hangout and we'll do this that and the other
and being able to actually show people - you know - Google -
draw - and so on - I find them
you know - to be not such a big deal ... the key thing is time zones;
that's managing the time zones that's something we struggle with all the
time
... we're working on software to support us you know helping
people find each other but that definitely is a big challenge.
But going back to the technologies in general you could kind of make this sort of
list between
the best to the worst communication experiences, going from
face-to-face through big immersive video conferencing set-ups,
standard video conferencing set-ups, then web conferencing which I guess we've got Google Hangouts and
you could call Skype in there as well; phone conferences which I think people generally ...
personally I think I would almost rather have
an IM chat with people than a phone conference
in as much as I can type quite fast and I can link to ... take a look at this, take
a look at that.
Phone conferences almost one of the most frustrating things in the world personally in my
opinion
but there is you know Wikis and forums, which is maybe a little better than email
and maybe better than no communication. I mean I think all these different ... I'm
not a big fan of ranking these things from best to worst; that's sort of what some other people are doing
... in some ways I think all of these different technologies have
different places and different roles that they can be used in managing a
distributed team
... in terms of you know communicating with a large, say you had 15,000
students all studying the same thing online
you know. We'll go into each of these
in more detail next week but
all of these things ... the technology has come on
from I think where it was making the whole
Agile process something that you can do in a distributed setting
so - you know - if you're having these distributed meetings and you're doing Agile and are you doing (and you
happen to be distributed)
I think some key things that are important are allowing for at least a little bit of small
talk
to allow the people in the distributed group to sort of connect to each other
... if you're in ... let's say a Hangout you know or
a phone conference and you are introducing the speaker, that's very important. Trying to work out some
kinda balance with the documentation of the meeting. We tend to -
tend to
record all of the videos so that people can catch up by watching those at some point. If there was an
AI system that would like automatically transcribe notes that would be really handy.
Mixing it up, making changes ... we'll talk about scrum
next and about moving from you know people focused scrums to project focused scrums
backwards and forwards.
But basically - trying make sure that the procedures
are clear ... really that's one
of the most important things for ...
getting ... these meetings not to explode in terms of the amount of time that they take
... and we've talked already about distributed software development but I think
these kinda things
that ... having continuous integration set up, using
pull requests, having this general model of: "right
there's going to be as much automation as possible to check the work that's
being done as possible,
we're gonna have fantastic transparency
for everyone to be able to see what other people are suggesting about what's going on with
the code
and so on" do make Agile work in a distributed
setting and we'll show you various examples of that in the next section
... we've been doing it for over a year now
with AgileVentures and it seems to be working extremely well.  Alright bye for now.